>> Hi, good evening, this is Ambuj Chaturvedi.
To answer the question whether India can become
a superpower or not,
the obvious answer is yes, because eventually
we will arrive at that
spot.
We -- the transformation process is starting,
has begun since '91, so
India is not looking back.
Now the second part of the question would
be what does it take to be a
superpower and when can become a superpower?
So what is the definition of a superpower?
Nuclear weapons, good roads, good railways,
good infrastructure, good
power, good power facilities, zero power cuts,
women's education, equal
rights.
India will arrive at all those -- India will
arrive at all those
avenues, all those milestones will be achieved.
But, the difficult -- the difficult question
will be how quickly?
Because you have a billion people.
You have a billion people and the biggest
problem is just what today's
last session was, when the mars problems come
in the last five years,
these problems are going to be the crucial
ones if you need to watch
out for.
Because a change, a change is slow.
We're not like China, we're not dictator,
we're not dictator.
So change will be slow.
What our biggest concern is to watch out for
Mars emergency problems
just come up.
Who knows what other problems will come up
because of the amount of
inequality which is there in the country.
So we need to see how quickly we can, we can
eliminate inequality in
the country.
That needs to be the key question.
Can India become a superpower?
Yes, it can.
That's where I would like to end.